à faire se dresser les cheveux sur la
tête
mais qu'on ne s'y trompe pas ni train
fantôme ni château hanté nous sommes
dans une école maternelle alia ritz en
plein pays basque ici voilà un mot qu'on
se prépare à halloween un mois qu'on se
prépare au grand frisson jus ce qu'on
met dans la pression
ils savent tous désormais du potiron
mais ce qu'il préfère ce sont les
sorciers n'ont pas hésité à dire bah
nous ça nous fait peur
nous ça nous fait pas peur mais mes
mamans vas-y ouvre l'armoire
moi je me repas mais oui j'ai pas peur
quand même ça c'est intéressant c'est la
cinquième année que biarritz cède à la
tentation d'halloween
et ce n'est pas un coup du sort si la
fed feront si bien au pays basque corps
des légendes et de sorcellerie on c'est
ici en france étaient des histoires
qu'est devenue cette sorcière n'en sais
rien ce plan c c'est que quelques temps
plus tard n'a entendu dans la nuit un
petit peu plus loin dans le pays denis
racine à sa douce que cette pénurie qui
m'a amené chez les celtes halloween a
traversé l'atlantique jusqu'aux états
unis avec les ja lempdes était au 19e
siècle
aujourd'hui en france personne ne peut
prédire l'avenir d'halloween même les
sorcières dans sa venue